man called Josiah's inna has become the
first to experiment on himself using
gene doping to potentially give himself
super strength no really
so this might sound like science fiction
but it's true it seems that the era of
transhumanism is just around the corner
so this ex NASA biochemist basically use
a technique called CRISPR cast 9 to
modify his own DNA potentially making
himself much stronger so CRISPR is a
technique that allows scientists and
researchers to relatively cheaply in an
affordably alter their own DNA it can
find target sites in the genome slice it
and then make edit to delete specific
parts or insert new information he's
knocked out a gene that causes the
production of myostatin myostatin is a
molecule that breaks down muscle mass
and if we can block myostatin we know
that this results in increased muscle
and somewhere up to 30% potentially
knockout mice have have this gene doping
technique done to them and they see a
massive increase in muscle mass with no
noticeable side effects you can see in
photos they go from being relatively
skiing normalized to super mice like
Mighty Mouse likewise you can breed the
myostatin gene out of dogs and bulls and
this has been done to result in huge
muscular looking animals and what's
really interesting is that this mutation
appears to occur naturally in certain
individuals so baby was born several
years ago now probably 10 years ago you
have this natural mutation and was just
this really strong can baby that could
perform the Iron Cross had huge curves
the foetus looked insane it's been
suggested that you can get a lesser
version of this mutation and that some
athletes might actually be walking
around that mutation right now one
example being flex wheeler he's often
suggested to be someone who might have
this mutation naturally I don't know why
flex of all the bodybuilders but yeah
that's a thing so if you're somebody who
gains muscle very easily doesn't lose it
easily then maybe you've got some kind
of mutation that's helping you along the
way I find it's really interesting
actually cuz once this specific mutation
is incredibly rare when you think about
the complexity of DNA the chances of one
of your pieces of code being slightly
different is actually not that
far-fetched you might be walking around
with some kind of low key superpower and
not even know it we're all so different
and that's why you should never judge
someone you know for finding it hard to
gain
for finding it easy to lose weight
because they might have a literally
different genome to you they might be so
different the way that we think might be
so different I just find it interesting
this great that we're all so different
so yeah the point is this mutation
blocking my staff and could result in
extra strength extra muscle with no
noticeable side effects there are no
side effects noted in this baby child
who had the mutation either and that's
what Josiah was interested in what he
wanted to demonstrate anyone to show how
now CRISPR makes it easy for anyone with
a basic understanding of biochemistry
even some basic equipment to perform
self gene therapy and to make changes to
their own body that he believes that we
should all be entitled to make these
changes to our own DNA to express
ourselves to become the person we really
want to be to direct our own evolution
not this was all about so he says it's
too early to see any results at this
point of the experiment and that was
never the point anyway there's only in
his forearm they would have only
affected the surrounding area but his
points to demonstrate this is something
that anyone can do and in his opinion
that anyone should be able to do you
just want to say right now I'm not
recommending that you run out there and
find a dodgy scientist who can do this
for you there are definitely risk
associated there's a chance of
insertional mutagenesis basically means
the cell goes bad it could potentially
cause cancer or other issues if you
delete the wrong gene or overwrite an
important and it's just not a very good
idea we don't know the long-term effects
at all and most of us don't have the
techniques or the science of the
knowledge to be able to do this so I'm
not saying this is something available
I'm not saying something you should do
I'm just saying it's really interesting
why I want to know as well you think
this is a good thing or a bad thing so
this falls under the category of
transhumanism transhumanism is
discussing any technology being used to
increase our abilities and better than
well so instead of using medical
techniques in order to cure disease or
fix problems it's using them to make us
faster stronger smarter more resilient
to disease to give us thicker skins that
won't burn as easily and there are those
out there that think this is a fantastic
idea that it gives us more freedom to be
whoever we want to be to advanced
civilization by making us smarter so we
can invent greater things to move us
towards the singularity to explore space
without worrying about the effects of
gravity
or cosmic rays there are lots of
potential benefits it couldn't even have
benefits for the planet by making us
more energy-efficient by making us need
less food all these things and of course
as someone who's interested in improving
themselves I'm just like the idea of men
of runty capacity jump super high and
pumped really hard and think smart
however there are also people that think
transhumanism is a very bad idea that it
will increase the class divide because
if something can't afford these
technologies to make themselves smarter
and faster and stronger and others can't
then of course that's going to create a
lot of issues likewise there are people
that say it's cheating I mean if I put
all this work into the gym to get
super-strong and then some guy comes
along and ejects himself and a
super-strong thirty percent more muscle
mass with no effort then how am I going
to be happy about that but that is that
just my issue and then should these
people be allowed to compete in the
Olympics there's no way of tracing a
gene modification and the blurry line
the confusion here is that if someone
already could have this mutation
naturally then wouldn't giving yourself
that mutation be simply the leveling the
playing field where do you draw the line
and isn't using some kind of shoe that
Springs you along actually a form of
transhumanism
here's transhumanism anything that's
permanent or do you count something like
caffeine or certainly nootropics where
do you draw that line there are contact
lenses an example of transhumanism or is
Plastic Surgery it's a really
interesting complicated topic I did my
dissertation on this actually on the
ethics of transhumanism I'd love to hear
your thoughts on that down below I'm not
a hundred percent sure where I stand on
it I think any technology we introduced
has a tendency to course travel make
things worse for a while and now as we
get used to it it makes things better
that's not a comment on whether we
should do it or not it's certainly
something that needs to be handled with
a lot of care and caution my conclusion
of that study by the way was that we
shouldn't use a blanket term
transhumanism
and found transhumanism or allow it but
rather look at the specific categories
within it we should create categories of
different types of transfer ISM and
different trans human technologies and
same is not the only example of go out
there already using trans human
technologies biohack got me is a website
where people discuss this sort of thing
and techniques they can use today to
improve themselves so one of the most
popular techniques on there is inserting
a small magnet into
their fingertips where they have lots of
nerve endings and then this vibrates
when they pass through magnetic fields
and electromagnetic fields and this
allows them to sense them to sense
microwaves for example and this
basically gives them a whole additional
sense on top of their regular senses
pretty exciting stuff not something I
would do because a I'm squeamish be a
lot of people get infections doing it
and see I need my finger I type on the
computer for a living and I left wait so
I wouldn't be able to do either of those
things with a uncomfortable magnet
moving around in there but again it's
certainly very interesting another guy
called Kevin Warwick actually inserted
an electrode array into his spine and
could use this to move a robotic arm
remotely and even to communicate with
his wife pretty crazy stuff so yeah for
now these transhuman technologies are
still very much in their own can see
they're not available and it's more to
something we need to start thinking
about and discussing and that's what
this video is about but maybe you're
wondering and I know you are if there's
a way that you can reduce your myostatin
production naturally and I'll go into
this in the future in more detail
perhaps but for now basically my
excessive production is linked with
cortisol and low blood sugar so you want
to stay as anabolic as possible if you
want to reduce your marks at in
production avoid really low blood sugar
avoid exerting yourself overly avoid
stress and you'll also avoid myostatin
there are products out there that claim
they can block myostatin most of these
involve increasing fala statin which is
naturally antagonistic to myostatin but
none of them are backed by studies less
than the scans it can be very expensive
only available online my recommendation
is to stay clear of those but if you do
try one let me know how it turns out for
you in the comments down below there is
research being done into antibodies that
could block my stuff in production so
mainly that will be available in the
future and more recent research has
shown that epic capuchin can also block
my static production epic estrogen being
a substance as available in dark
chocolate I've talked about dark
chocolate before and how it has tons of
benefits for vasodilation and
all kinds of other stuff for brain power
so if you're interested in blocking my
statin then you could try switching from
white chocolate to dark chocolate or
making duck chocolate your daily snack
because it's also the health benefits
and it's not expensive there's no
downside if it doesn't do anything for
you and that's what I do but so yeah
there you have it
gene doping is upon us transhumanism is
upon us and
myostatin is an interesting Avenue to
pursue if you want to build more muscle
hope Frank's been a useful interesting
guys who did them please leave a like
please share around please comment down
below these things will help me greatly
I massively appreciate it
if you found this interesting then stay
tuned subscribe to channel I've got more
on the way on brain training
bodybuilding fitness martial arts
productivity no crow clicks all the
usual stuff if that sounds good
then thanks a ton for watching and bye
for now
[Music]